>> Vincent Dureau: So let me show you something
else.
So Rishi here is carrying his own Android
remote which by the way is paired to the same
box as I am, so that we can have two remote
controls controlling the same box at the same
time so that we don't need to fight for the
remote.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vincent Dureau: And of course, Rishi couldn't
help it. While I was speaking, he was browsing
the Web, and he came up with a really neat
Web site that he wants to share with us. But
he doesn't want to share it on the small screen.
He wants to share it on the big screen. So
how are you going to do that?
>>Rishi Chandra: Well, let me see -- the Wi-Fi
is kicking me off back and forth, so let me
see if I can get on really quickly. It will
a....
Okay. Let's see. All right. I am on. Hopefully
it stays on.
>>Vincent Dureau: I know you can do it.
>>Rishi Chandra: I am watching a cool video
here, so I am actually watching it on my phone,
enabled in Flash, of course.
Let's go ahead and take a look and see if
I can stay on again and push it directly to
the TV.
[ Applause ]
>>Vincent Dureau: Voila.
(Video Playing).
>>> Conan O'Brien: Lick your fingers first.
[ Laughter ].
>>Vincent Dureau: Wow! Rishi, that was a very
special video you shared with us.
>>Rishi Chandra: Even better than what we
were watching on TV before.
>>Vincent Dureau: Of course. All right.
So this is just the beginning. Why? Because
actually we are going to publish this IP remote
control protocol so that you developers can
build your own apps and your own remote controls
on the device of your choice, be it a PC,
a smartphone, or a tablet, to enhance the
Google TV experience.
All right of the so that's pretty much the
story about the hardware.
[ Applause ]
>>Vincent Dureau: Rishi, do you want to tell
us about the software?
>>Rishi Chandra: Yeah. Can we pull back the
slides, please, although I would love to keep
watching this video. It's pretty funny.
All right. So let me talk a little bit about
the software. So the Google TV has three components
to the stack. The first is Android. We are
built on Android 2.1, and we will be upgrading
to later versions of Android over time, because
we have the ability to do over-the-air updates.
Second, the browser. We are Google Chrome.
We needed a full Web compatible browser to
be able to browse everything that's out there.
We chose the fastest.
And finally, if you want to be fully compatible
with all the Web video content out there,
you need to have Flash. So we also have a
full Flash 10.1 plug-in as part of chrome.
And that's the software.
One thing we haven't talked too much about
yet is Android.
One of the benefits of being built on Android
and chrome is not only can we deliver great
Web applications to users, we can also deliver
Android apps.
Wouldn't it be cool if I can take my favorite
mobile app and actually just have it work
on my TV?
Soon, you can.